الاتصالات السريه سبق وان حدثت خلال عهد
ترامب كان النقاش يدور ايضا حول امكانيه
ان تسحب واشنطن قواتها العسكريه من سوريا
لم يتحقق الامر في عهد ترامب بل ان
الاتصالات انقطعت تماما بعد الرئيس
الامريكي السابق في قتل الاسد وهو ما منعه
ما هو معارضه وزير دفاعه وقتها جيمس ترامب
هو من صرح بذلك وعلنا
مع عدم وجود رغبه واشنطن في انهاء وجودها
في سوريا ما هي اولوياتها هناك اذا نهايه
عام 2021 عقب مراجعه الحكومه الامريكيه
سياساتها تجاه سوريا حددت بعض الاولويات
اهمها الحفاظ على زخم مكافحه داعش وضمان
عدم عودته ويشمل ذلك تدريب وتسليح
المقاتلين الاكراد وقوات قصد
يستمر القتال في هذه المرحله ضد داعش انت
تعلم انه يمكننا باستمرار ان نضعف قدراتهم
الخاصه بالقياده والسيطره وقدرتهم على
الاستيلاء على اي ارض والسيطره عليها
هذه هي الاولويه الخاصه بداعش تشكك بها
روسيا صاحبه الوجود العسكريه الوازن في
سوريا ومنذ ثمان سنوات بالنظر الى تدهور
قوه وقدره داعش بشكل كبير اولويه واشنطن
هذه ايضا تعرضها تركيا من جهه اخرى التي
تتحفظ على كل ما من شانه زياده النفوذ
الكردي على حدودها الجنوبيه او زياده قوه
الاكراد بالدعم الامريكي اولويه اخرى
لواشنطن في سوريا لكن هذه المره تحدثت
عنها بكين
النقط السوري
الجيش الامريكي لا يزال يحتل المناطق
الخاصه بانتاج الحبوب والنفط الرئيسيه في
سوريا وينهب الثروات الوطنيه السوريه مما
يفقهم الازمه الانسانيه المحليه
تتفاوضوا امريكا مع سوريا سرا لمراجعه
الوجود العسكري وفي وقت يؤكد البيت الابيض
عدم التراجع عن الانتشار المستمر منذ ما
يقرب من ثماني سنوات في سوريا وذلك بعد ان
صوت مجلس النواب الامريكي برفض قرار سحب
القوات الامريكيه من سوريا
سوطاثه مشرعين لصالح القرار
و321 ضده اول دفعه من القوات الامريكيه
جاءت في اكتوبر عام 2015 وبلغ عددها 50
جنديا من القوات الخاصه دورهم كان
استشاريا لا قتليا نهايه عام 2016 وصل
العدد الى 500 جندي واليوم 900 هو الرقم
المعلن رسميا هؤلاء ينتشرون في المنطقه
المعروفه باسم منطقه شرق سوريا الامنيه
ضمن محافظتي الحسكه
ودير الزور
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات